well dr merna dewmet is the president of
the order of nurses in lebanon
she says the situation in hospitals in
beirut is catastrophic
hospitals are not only overwhelmed we
have
three hospitals that are completely
destroyed
so we had to evacuate patients who were
in those hospitals to other hospitals
in addition we have two other hospitals
that were partially
destroyed so it was a catastrophe it was
a big hit to the head care system who
was already
or the hospital system in lebanon that
is already
bleeding so the situation is
catastrophic and
very sadly i say that we lost
three nurses three nurses who were
working at the hospital and they are
dead
so i don't find words to describe what
happened
it's a we've never seen
such a thing i was personally on the
road
and i saw the explosion i heard two
uh explosions and then i
started seeing
the wounded people and
we started the operation on the ground
we had to ask
other hospitals to accept patients to
accept
injured people we start the red cross
started evacuating
the hospitals that were completely
demolished and uh we have
lots of wounded wounded people we have
death
and um situation cannot
be described really it's it's a it's
like we're we're living in a horror film